we start with a question that's on the
minds of many Americans well I guess I
know where we was almost off those trips
oh well we know tonight that we can
report of course Matt Lauer is no longer
the anchor over at the Today Show fired
overnight and reportedly with no warning
Lauer is the second morning network
anchor to fall in just a week they had
one of the biggest runs on television
ever most profitable franchise in
television history and NBC said the
firing followed recent accusations from
one co-worker but Variety magazine they
did their own two-month investigation
published today and found evidence of a
lot more wider and abusive conduct hours
after that the New York Times reported
two more claims and Lauer's co-workers
Savannah Guthrie Hoda copy well learned
of the news of his firing just before
they reported it at the top of the Today
Show that's quite an opening and they
all and their colleagues at 30 rock were
visibly shaken by this news all we can
say is that we are heartbroken I'm
heartbroken for Matt he is my dear dear
friend and my partner and he is beloved
by many many people here how do you
reconcile your love for someone with the
revelation that they have behaved badly
I've known Matt for 15 years it's hard
to reconcile what we are hearing with
the man who we know who walks in this
building every single day I texted him
this morning said not a adore you and
and and no person is perfect in this
world nobody is my thoughts of course
are with Matt he's been a friend he's
been he's been a mentor he's been a guy
you could watch a guy who led by his
example on the set I am stunned by this
I've known Matt for 25 years I consider
him to be a friend Willie was apt in his
description of Matt then again maybe
there were some warning signs just below
the radar
back in 2012 Lauer's longtime co-host
Katie Couric said something in
interview that didn't get much notice at
the time but maybe it should have the
today's show with Matt Lauer for 15
years what is Matt's most annoying habit
he pinches me on the Athlon lovely sound
it kind of a sour face there Katie
wasn't kidding and that's kind of
genuine disgust and it makes you wonder
how NBC supposedly missed this for all
these years also getting a close second
look is a Today Show promo that seemed
to openly hint at Lauer's reputation for
inappropriate behavior with ladies and
possibly a habit of I don't know walking
around without his pants again well I
mean NBC claims none of their current
leadership knew about Lauer's past but
it seems hard to believe now to help us
make sense of all of this the shockwaves
in the media world will bring in Fox
News media analysts how he Kurtz one
thing that was interesting today Joe
Flint tweeted the following he said NBC
News doubles down we can unequivocally
say power - prior to Monday night
current NBC news management was never
made aware of any complaints about
Lauer's conduct said the network current
NBC management Jeff Zucker over at CNN
was the executive producer of The Today
Show for many years very successful and
he had a very terse statement through a
spokesperson today
Howie that there was never a complaint
filed against him during his time there
that's that's it well the complaint part
might be true but it certainly raises a
lot of questions about who and NBC
management very times knew about this an
NBC Laura tried to seize the moral high
ground by saying well we fired Matt
Lauer as soon as we got this complaint
36 hours and is true then BC took swift
action but clearly this was a preemptive
move before the variety piece comes out
with allegations about him giving a sex
toy to a co-worker
summoning exposing himself to know the
world there's a photo apparently that
they have now right I mean this is
pretty graphic stuff and in New York
Times peace talks about a woman who said
she did have sex in 2001 Matt Lauer that
she felt pressured to save her job so
NBC tried to control the narrative by
not putting out much detail on getting
out ahead of these reports that shows
that these allegations have been out
there for some time well just going back
to Jeff Zucker though I mean it's kind
of it reminds me kind of of what we were
hearing about Harvey Weinstein that
oh I'm shocked can't believe it hearted
every Weinstein but then you heard I
mean I had heard about Harvey Weinstein
back in 1997 I was on The Today Show a
bunch of times I was like Matt Lauer I
seem funny I'm a liberal guy but it was
not nothing but you know nice to me so I
had very minimal interaction with him
but from the Katie Couric comment to
that odd promo there were a couple of
other things that have popped up on tape
it's a little it's a little strange for
a network that prides itself on being so
Pro women and we're all from girl power
and it's a little odd and Jeff Zucker he
doesn't come out on camera today this is
one of his old friends old buddies
nothing you have to cringe looking at
some of these now skits and what Katie
Couric said and all of that but you know
what happens is the environment has
changed so whereas it might have been
easy for NBC and other networks Laura
other networks have had these problems
in power yes yes but to look the other
way to not take it seriously to turn a
blind eye to what some of the women who
were complaining in the era of Harvey
Weinstein and all the politicians now Al
Franken and Roy Moore John Conyers being
killed for a while so now you can't get
away with it so CBS dumps Charlie Rose
why do i NBC dumps Matt Lauer right away
but there are a lot of unanswered
questions here but what who knew what
and was NBC allows they're not they're
not revealing the name of the young
woman who said in 2014 he approached her
at the Olympic right now I think that
maybe because that woman and perhaps
other women are not ready to come go
forward and you couldn't understand them
not one
have their lives blown up but at the
same time it just fuels I mean this is
sort of the beginning of the stories a
lot more to know about this and the way
that networks now respond to these kinds
of allegations and who knew what went
this is the revenge of Ann Curry someone
wrote today anchor that's air ammonia
Deborah Norville other people who wanted
to talk to him I'd like to hear from all
of them I appreciate how he thanks so
much it's